everybody knew flash four-night
crossover stuff going on you guys asked
me to do a new video and I know it feels
like there's not a lot going on right
now but they actually just finished
filming flash episode 4 so the really
big news is is that we might know what
the titles are for the four episodes of
the crossover I'm treating these like
working titles these might change but
the way they read like sort of the
simplistic big bombastic way they read
sound like something that they would
actually do because if you remember what
they did last season is they had this
really big pitch big four night
crossover that was really more of a
three night crossover they called the
flash episode the arrow episode in the
legends episode invasion it was all the
same title and it was just the title of
the comic book arc where the dominators
come and invade with the alien Alliance
so there was a lot of stuff that they
didn't do they really just did the
dominators in the comic book version to
that story there were several alien
groups and earlier this year Markku
geun-hye was talking about how he and
greg berlanti were planning up next
year's crossover in his reaction to
their conversation was how do you do
something that's bigger than aliens they
only fought them off because TV Justice
League or Super Friends they have the
haul of Super Friends so I guess Super
Friends would probably be the best term
for them destroy their metahuman bombs
so the dominators sort of tucked their
tail between their legs in take off but
now we have for like a true four night
crossover in the working title sound
like they're going to be greater foes
part 1 on Supergirl
then remember arrow is the next episode
that's greater loss than part 3 that's
the flash episode greater threat and
then the legends episode greater menace
so the titles are very simplistic but
they imply that it's a much greater
thing that's going on than was last
season so the Supergirl title implies
that it's going to be a group it's not
going to be a single person because it
says greater foes it would just say
greater foe if it was going to be one
person so that makes me think it's less
likely that it's Mongol in war world
that's the threat because that sounds
like more of a singular thing but there
is a race that exists on war world
they're just called the war zones so
those could be the greater foes that
they're referring to but there are a
couple of elements that like these pg-13
big action set-pieces require you've
probably heard about this
when Suicide Squad came out so during
that movie remember how enchantress and
her brother converted all those regular
people into sort of like walking rock
men that the Suicide Squad would then
just destroy and they would crumble into
rocks so it was a way to do bloodless
action and allow the heroes to smash the
hell out of the villains without making
them seem like serial killers which is
funny because the Suicide Squad is made
up of villains they are serial killers
that's why they're imprisoned but you
get the idea DC TV is firmly in pg-13
territory so if they're going to be
fighting and beating the crap out of a
giant group of people then they
typically favor non-human villains they
also in the name of efficiency also
feature a lot of moments with the heroes
fighting themselves I'm hoping they
don't double down on that but part two
the arrow episode greater loss implies
that they get their asses handed to them
in that Supergirl episode so whoever it
is it's someone that's powerful enough
to handle her ass and that's why she
needs to get the others to help out holy
crap this is too big for me they're only
a couple of big space-based villains
that can do that to her
they're probably cleared to do on TV
because normally you would just say
apocalypse like the forces of apocalypse
Darkseid but of course because they're
doing that for the Justice League movie
there's no way they're going to do it on
TV so like the next step down from
Darkseid really is mongol and war world
unless they want to pull another
space-based race that they did not use
from the dominator story arc so the
invasion storyline has the okarin and a
bunch of other big space-based races but
whoever it is it sounds like they kill a
whole bunch of people because otherwise
why would you call the episode greater
loss and make it sound like a huge
bummer
the flash title greater threat implies
that things get more complicated but not
necessarily better
so usually after the heroes get their
asses handed to them they come together
they take the villains down under normal
circumstances this would be the last
part of the crossover and they'd resolve
it but because it's four nights it
sounds like the villains either gain
some power or it's like a villain team
that comes together and they become a
greater threat because they obtain some
item or some object that makes them even
more powerful than they were before
which sounds pretty standard fare for
your big super hero team-up villain
wants something that will give them
power they mowed through the heroes on
their way to get it they achieved that
power and in the heroes had to find some
way to take that power from them
they've already done legion of Doom's so
I'm crossing my fingers for like a big
comic book team-up like secret society
of super villains or something like that
if they're not going to be aliens and
then I love the title of legends of
tomorrow because normally this would be
like something really hopeful because
it's the last part like yeah you know
heroes victorious but because the title
is greater Menace it implies that even
though the heroes will defeat the
villains like this is just the arc of
things things ended a really hopeful way
but it implies that whatever the
resolution is the villains are still out
there they're still an ongoing menace to
the heroes so I know there are a lot of
questions about what's going on with
each of the show's and how they come
together for the crossover so arrow
flash and Supergirl are all in present
day things are relatively normal Legends
is really the only more complicated show
because when you collapse time you have
something from the year 3000 coexisting
in the same space with a dinosaur it
remains to be seen how much that is
going to affect the vents on the other
TV shows because I've heard the theories
that this is all happening in an
alternate timeline they haven't really
said anything about that it's the only
way in my mind to explain how you can
have episodes in the earth one universe
with flash and arrow that don't have
dinosaurs running around in present day
because legends did the very thing where
they just completely mess with the
timeline in a slightly different way but
it's the same result time is completely
broken let me know in the comments what
do you guys think about the titles do
those sound plausible
they sound like working titles now
there's still not going to air till much
later this year so they could always
change those that they want but remember
they generally keep the titles of those
episodes very simple and easy to follow
for people that haven't read the comics
and things that are easy to market so
greater threat greater menace greater
foes it all sounds like something that
they would do we just don't know what
the single tagline is that they're
really going to use to market it because
that would probably tip the hat to who
the villain is going to be and wind up
being a big spoiler but what's going to
happen is once we get to September is
when they'll probably start dropping new
footage I've seen them drop Supergirl
promos but those are mostly just remixes
of old footage right now they just
finished filming flash episode 4
or they said it was a little bit longer
Tom Cavanagh was directing so it sounds
like it's going to be a pretty big deal
he wound up directing some of the crazy
episodes last season and they said that
he'd be doing that even more this year
so if he's directing it means they're
doing something really big with the new
character or they're doing something
really crazy that they've never tried
before so I'm assuming that episode four
is going to be the lead up or set the
stage for the arrival of the elongated
man just because he's one of the big new
characters but you guys may have also
seen 250 Deathstroke episodes on arrow
there are two Deathstroke episodes
they're going to tell his origin story
start with episode 5 so you have five
six then seven break in eight the
crossover so arrow is going to be crazy
the first half of the season they've
been way more tight-lipped about what
the flash is doing just I think to
maintain an era of secrecy but they've
been very upfront like we are bringing
Deathstroke back the title of Part 1 is
going to be Deathstroke returns so we
can freak out about that but there'll be
more arrow and flash coming in the next
month as we start to wind up for those
so leave all your requests for bonus
videos in the comments below and there
will be a new round of the flash ring
giveaway I'll still be doing that this
season all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber leave a comment on this
video announce the winner the next time
I post a DC video well we got some new
Game of Thrones and some new defenders
posting next so while you guys wait for
everything you can click here for more
new flash season 4 and you can click
here for brand new defenders thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you